um motel a todos agradeço muito a
oportunidade está aqui eu sou médico e
um médico meio esquisito eu sou o
patologista
em outras palavras eu vejo o doença ruim
a gente que morreu e isso me e também
tem uma outra característica que eu
nasci em são paulo
no quarto centenário da cidade então o
são paulo não por qualquer força mística
ou divina mas que houve uma epidemia
gripal luz quando a cidade sonhava em
ser moderna com a dor a gente sonhava
que nós vamos construir uma metrópole
amistosa cultural e também é
desenvolvida é infelizmente o uso de
andrade morreu naquele ano e não pode
ver no que a cidade se transformou mas
uma coisa eu posso dizer são paulo é uma
cidade é que ela é não é amor à primeira
vista mas que ela tem personalidade ela
tem a gente descobre a cidade nos
pequenos detalhes dos pequenos comércios
nos grammys que ocorrem é nas esquinas a
bicicleta me ajudou a encher nessa
cidade melhor pois ela tem um tempo que
permite que eu enxergasse a cidade
além dos hepatologista paulistano suas
matiko ea e todo o chelsea dia uma sonda
viva de como as condições no ambiente da
cidade da poluição strans um asmático
facebook quando fica nervoso
osmar se confessa um bom que quando a
umidade cai quando esfria
quando eu respiro à poluição então eu
conseguir de alguma forma entender que
aquela cidade não só fazia parte do meu
coração mas também dos meus pulmões e
principalmente da minha alma e e o fato
de poder ter duvidoso privilégio depois
como profissional de enxergar os sinais
da cidade de são paulo dentro dos corpos
que eu abro que eu vejo como a cidade
pode tratar bem o mal os seus habitantes
me fez ampliar enormemente o conceito de
compra
são de saúde e comecei a estudar com
aquilo que mais me interessava que era a
poluição do ar jorge porque eu era um
óbvio sensor do que me afetar
aliás médico tem isso é meio esquisito
vai ser psiquiatra você vai começar a
tentar resolver os seus problemas e vai
ser é procurando através da sua cura
curar o próximo e distribuir digamos
melhor bem que se possa mas eu também
fui observando porque são paulo
quando ela quis e moderna elas indenizou
vamos lembrar de uma cidade que era
primitiva uma cidade botocudos se falava
a língua geral que até hoje aparece em
nome dos bairros das ruas os monumentos
uma cidade que toda vez que descobrir se
alguma coisa valiosa no brasil as
cidades baseava e de repente ela começa
a no seu projecto de uma cidade
civilizada
numa cidade que mais crescia do mundo
que a gente sonhava com o hertha vá a
idéia do desenvolvimento ela começou
então se dedicar ao embelezamento ea
produção da beleza também uma outra
justificativa para essa falha dizer que
a gente nota aqueles que vão praxe e
usam o trem
o mesmo indivíduo o mesmo bípede tem um
comportamento distinto a depender no
seguimento da linha férrea que ele está
um comportamento no metrô e outro na
cptm
será então que nós enxergamos o estético
e o belo vantagem esses espaços vermos
esses pontos de encontro às experiências
de iluminação do espírito ele se
traduzem no nosso organismo sob a forma
de comportamento ou mesmo da sua
biologia é esse assunto começou me
fascinar qual o papel da organização
urbana porque as cidades quando começam
a se desenvolver
ela dedica uma parte substancial da sua
energia a lg monumentos templos
basicamente criadas a partir da força da
criatividade humana muito do que a gente
conhece de civilização só foi possível
na cidade e ouvir como uma necessidade
biológica de se construir catedrais
templos monumentos escrever obras muito
antes de você conhecer por exemplo o
cálculo conhecer fatores foram
fundamentais que desenvolve uma
organização não foi uma conseqüência de
um processo de um progresso ou num
processo intelectual mas sim a beleza a
estética precedeu o formalismo teórico e
conceitual no no organismo
algumas espécies são óbvias que conversa
através de sinais sons e cantos aves são
assim nós o canto ao o dimorfismo é e as
pelagem dos animais sinalizam atitudes
posturas visões com fazem com que as
pessoas que os animais se organizem
saibam quando podem se aproximar quando
podem ser afastar do outro
qual o momento da procriação qual é o
momento da fuga
isso nós vamos ver
ou ainda as cavernas do paleolítico e
vamos ver aonde tiver a pintura é também
o momento é são os locais da caverna uma
daquelas habitações daquelas pessoas que
se abrigavam em organizada em grupos de
30 a 40 pessoas e 50 mas é o lugar onde
tinha melhor custo
então é muito provável que a decisão de
sobreviver ao mundo hostil fosse
decidido sobre a musa de uma parede
pintada e possivelmente ser levada com
cantos e todas as evidências mostram que
a pintura precedeu a escrita e o canto
precedeu a fala
aqueles grupamentos possivelmente
celebravam as suas decisões ou reuniões
emitindo sons
antes que você tivesse um alfabeto uma
gravata
se isso for verdade na escala evolutiva
nós devemos ter algum receptor para
beleza ou seja nós não sentimos o tato
audição gustação calor dor mas algo
muito mais sutil que penetra em nossos
corpos ilumina as almas demanda nós muda
a nossa fisiologia
será que isso é verdade
bom por incrível que pareça médicos
começaram a estudar isso os efeitos e
descobriu isso empiricamente mas como
todo e medicina
antes de desenvolver um remédio matamos
muito com um sanguessuga sou sangrias
mas se descobriu por exemplo que além da
sbim a a mudança dos hospitais da
estrutura dos hospitais não só tenham
princípios de higiene mas também se
começou a colocar beleza no hospital e
os pacientes começam a cuidar mais
depressa hospitais são mais vezes não só
por uma questão de hotelaria e você leva
teatro leva riso leva música nos
hospitais porque aquele sentimento de
desamparo aquela sensação de você tá
perdido ele é beneficiada em alguma
coisa é amenizada por coisas que vão
além do remédio além de qualquer outra
coisa que a gente está acostumado
entender como saúde
senão vejamos
se você pegar por exemplo teve gente que
estudou o efeito não tem uma história de
musicoterapia de charlatanismo
será que você ouve música bonita é
bonita pra cada um é o que pegamos um
exemplo aqui típico sertanejo
universitário pode ser bela para alguns
o inferno para o outro sem ser diferente
um show é desse tipo
um cruzeiro em alto mar por exemplo com
alguns cantores que fazem você é fã
daquele cantor aqui no paraíso
você não é 100 embarcou sem saber é o
inferno mostrando que o capeta em deus
economizar custos colocaram tudo no
mesmo pacote turístico muito bom se você
ouvir música que é bonita por seu
conjunto de valores o que acontece com a
sua pressão arterial cá
será que é só um relaxamento mas o que
acontece por exemplo com as regiões do
cérebro que coordenam estresse ativa de
novo o relaxamento do relaxamento também
a pessoa que ele é o cara o stress ea
sua secreção de cortisol hormônio
antiinflamatório a expressão gênica de
hormônios que vão qualificar seu estado
inflamatório são você momento que você
tem uma experiência sublime uma visão
bonita quando senta na capela sistina e
ver aquele teto
você não fica indiferente mas não é só a
sua mente a sua alma
os genes que codificam resposta
inflamatória são afetadas
se você for ver a secreção de muco globo
minas que vão pedir que morramos de
infecção
você tem todas as evidências
quantitativas objetivas de que a
ambiência mundo
a exposição albergue modifica o nosso
organismo de uma forma absolutamente
objetiva ou seja nós sentimos é a nossa
fisiologia é afetada por coisas nós
construímos a partir de uma inspiração
de uma poética e dilma é digamos
estética e por isso que faz parte da
biologia das sociedades humanas a
construir ambientes baseados no
encantamento hora
o que acontece quando falta quando não
se se você viver no bonito por ver
coisas têm oportunidade de ver coisas
belas e produzir tem uma biologia da
arte uma fisiopatologia da arte é
importante que acontece quando falta
isso também acontece o já foi estudado
por pensar as nossas vidas hoje a hoje a
gente vive tempos bicudos de um pode nem
ficar doente sempre o direito de
convencer você
isso também acontece com o bicho não é
só a gente é quando se vê uma máquina
por exemplo uma alcatéia só o lobo
dominante é que quando a doente pode
ficar na toca os outros se perceberem
são excluídos ou pagam punições também
existe essa diferente prerrogativa de
acesso ao repouso e ao direito de sofrer
mas como é hoje uma cidade a gente tem
amigos nós construímos a cidade de gaza
uma cidade e cada um tem a sua nasci na
cidade de são paulo é tão complexo que
não tem uma cidade só a minha e acho que
de todos vocês uma cidade que nasce no
coração da gente e vai até a onde moram
os nossos as pessoas que a gente ama os
lugares que a gente gosta
aí você vai perdendo as suas relações
afetivas que se construiu na infância na
voragem dos dias de hoje já não procura
o seu canto e você reconstrói as suas
relações hoje 1º na faculdade e depois
vocês e para depois do trabalho
você trabalha muito hoje quando você vai
se socializar você vai sair com seus
amigos do trabalho num pedaço da logo
acaba o expediente e chega enquanto a
aposentadoria não foi redefinida sabe
que geneticamente né
é toda vez que divide a cela você pega
um pedacinho da ponta do dna
e teoricamente o limite máximo da maior
parte das nossas células que você
consegue depois que encurtou a partir de
um determinado momento não dividir mais
então teoricamente o limite biológico da
bíblia em torno de 115 anos
então se aposentar com 65 é teoricamente
você tem 50 anos de lazer e se morrer
antes é problema seu
todos os hábitos da tua genética culpa
não é sua então é um programa de
humanização
é fazer a aposentadoria aos 65 anos no
entanto a gente aposenta e tem um ganhou
expectativa de vida e aí
aí você aquela relação de pessoas em
oportunidades encontro de discutir
idéias de ver teatro com os amigos de
visitar exposições as alternativas não
são muito animadoras e não soube criar
você tem aqui no submercado três vezes
podia conversar com o jornaleiro na
esquina né ouvirá síndico do prédio que
talvez seja o mais devastador né
muito bom aí você começa e têm em comum
o fato que divido e aposenta e morre
pouco depois que azar acabou de
aposentar ele morre talvez intoxicação
de comprar uma sandália havaiana é uma
vergonha de ficar na beira da praia é
sem ter o que fazer
aí morre o cônjuge o outro homem logo
depois fala num outro veio buscar meio
nada sabia se tiver morto a última coisa
que quero fazer visitar este planeta de
novo mas dá para levar alguém que talvez
se tenha criado discussões de deus em
caxias mortais em apoio a ele até estava
a pasta de dente no meio e eu vou te
levar agora esse mesmo indivíduo pra
cima de novo pra mim aporrinhar na e ou
não é isso
a solidão faz com que aquele tumor
latente
estava controlado por células de defesa
pela imunodepressão aflora aquela dieta
que você tem você começa a comer mal
você passa a controlar pior diabetes e
hipertensão
você perde os âncoras emocionados
então porque tudo o que se pode fazer e
todos os estudos de metal análises
mostram dizendo que se você quisesse
dizer mais
depois dos 60 comparando perder peso
deixar de fumar deixar de beber
praticar esporte academia g toxina né
porque a academia tem uma coisa muito
chata temos que não precisamos que não
tem jeito então você que não tem jeito
de polêmica quando vê os que não
precisam né
isso leva uma depressão é acadêmica
digamos assim não no sentido o acadêmico
à universidade mas acadêmico o essa essa
esse conjunto de coisas mostra que tudo
o que mostra que o aumento da
expectativa de vida e todos estes
fatores comparados o que mais aumenta a
expectativa de vida e manutenção de
relações afetivas sociais e mais a
capacidade de você a se encantar com os
eua em torno de você manter o espírito
vivo
portanto eu finalizo isso que depois com
muita gente que morreu
olhar muita coisa um microscópio e
colocar muito gênio
eu posso dizer que uma política cultural
consistente uma criação de espaços de
permanência de trocas de idéias não é
uma política artista não há política de
estética é na política também que não é
só de saúde
ela é de direitos humanos direitos
humanos porque faz o corte está escrito
no nosso dna que nós respondemos a tudo
isso que está em risco em nosso país
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]